you might notice that I'm dressed a
little bit unusually today i'm wearing a
hey treat male t-shirt this is one of
those t-shirts that i told you is
exclusively available through the
fundraiser we're running at david
pakman.com slash donate uh this is not a
t-shirt that you can get from the david
packard show online store this is a
t-shirt that is a donor at david
pakman.com slash donate you can select
as a perk and the coolest thing about
this shirt not only that it's available
in whatever size you want and whatever
color you want is that it was actually
designed by it one of our viewers we
have a dozen or so different hatred mail
banners that we use during hatred mail
on the show this is a sort of modified
version of one of those banners i'm
trying not to block it with my
microphone here we have this shirt
exclusively available for you through
the campaign we also have another
exclusive shirt available through the
campaign the established in 2005 david
pakman show seal shirt also you can
choose the size cuz Who am I to tell
people what size they need to buy right
if you can't allow people to have
self-determination and pick the size
t-shirt that they want in the color
t-shirt that they want I am not being a
good person but that t-shirt also
available path through the fundraiser
you've bought like 75 hundred of these
t-shirts so far haven't you only so far
yeah I plan to buy more especially
having seen you what model this design
in particular what color would you call
them this is called cantaloupe
officially this is the Sun color call in
it I feel like it does reflect don't you
think Rachel that if you think of the
flesh of a cantaloupe this is that color
yeah it's a it's on the nose yep we have
another color called moss we have a
color called pistachio which is very
much like I don't know about real
pistachios but it's definitely the color
of like fake pistachio colored ice cream
race it's that green color uh so yes
we're about to cross the nine thousand
dollar mark in the fundraiser almost 250
donors the average donation has crept up
from thirty-five dollars per donation
earlier this week to a little over
thirty six dollars per donation we are
raising money to create a progressive
engagement coordinator to organize
coordinate progressive actions on a
variety of issues we are organizing and
partnering with existing independent
progressive shows also to grow the
influence of progressive activism the
david pakman show studio it's ready for
just such an amazing upgrade a
professional set designer has been
submitting designs and were workshopping
them into the conclusion of this
campaign if it's successful we're going
to be having a significant overhaul and
upgrade of the studio a lot of really
really great stuff all donations are
welcome electoral colleges voted Trump
is in we are going into Trump's America
we must activate and I hope that you'll
donate whatever you can doesn't matter
if it's only a few bucks obviously if
you can top the UH biggest donation so
far which is four hundred ninety nine
dollars if you can replace that with an
even bigger donation as the top donation
by all means but even if you can only
donate a couple of bucks at david
pakman.com slash donate please do it we
will take a break send me your thoughts
about anything that's on your mind i'm
on twitter at d pakman